what's going on everybody not sure if
you've seen this yet but looks like
spider-man stealth suit could have been
revealed by a leaked photo reminder that
I'm doing a giveaway I'll put the
details below and I'll talk about it
more at the end of this video so in this
photo we see spider-man on top of a
ferris wheel in a black suit no it's not
venom I know a lot of people are
thinking that this is venom he's wearing
the Venom symbiote but it just doesn't
make any sense for that to happen the
most likely explanation for this is that
he's wearing his stealth suit it's very
interesting because in the comics he
creates this suit to fight the Hobgoblin
he creates it to combat the Hobgoblin
sonic screams because this suit has the
ability to warp sound around it as well
as light so it can also make him
invisible
so again it's interesting because he
creates it to fight the Hobgoblin it is
already rumored that there are going to
be a ton of villains in this movie as
well as the rumor that they might set up
the sinister six in this movie so could
we possibly see Hobgoblin in this movie
so again in the comics Peter Parker
actually creates the stealth suit but
the MCU version is very different
obviously Tony Stark is the one who gave
Peter Parker the nanotech suit
spider-man did not create it it's very
possible that the nanotech spider-man
suit simply has the ability to go in
what I would call a camouflage mode I'm
gonna get a little closer so I can see
what's happening would you like me to
engage in a hands to combat mode in
hence combat mode yeah activating
instant kill no no no no I don't want to
kill anybody
deactivating instant kill sort of blend
in with the surrounding environment so
if you're at night it would turn dark or
it can make you invisible I put a
tracker on someone he's a bad guy
another option that is very likely is
that he could get this suit from happy
or shield thanks to leaked photos and
videos we have already seen happy hogan
Nick Fury and Maria Hill on the set of
Spider Man far from home so we know that
they're going to be in the movie now we
don't really know what to deal with Tony
Stark is in Spider
far from home we don't know if he's
alive we don't know if he's dead retired
we have no idea we haven't seen him yet
but for whatever reason let's just say
that he's not in the movie
so maybe happy and pepper are looking
after him now that Tony's not there or
maybe shield is putting him on a special
mission and they gave him the suit all
of these are very possible options for
how he gets the suit and however he gets
it I'm super excited for it the stealth
suit is really awesome has a lot of
great capabilities and I'm super excited
to see it on-screen
I hope this is what it is but let me
know what you think in the comments
below and let me know how excited you
are to see spider-man far from home
another reminder about the giveaway I'm
giving away a copy of Avengers infinity
war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia from our partners at
silk and cotton all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching Wolf Wolf
come on wash that - we are yellow $10
[Music]